E
AGAIN A NET EXPORTER OF ENERGY,
BUT HE KNOWS A THING OR TWO
ABOUT ENERGY AS TEXAS SENATOR
TED CRUZ.
SENATOR, I WOULD IMAGINE INSTEAD
OF DOING AN IDIOTIC DEAL WITH
IRAN AND SUCKING UP THE
MURDERING THUG DICTATOR IN
VENEZUELA, MA DURA, AND BEGGING
OPEC ONLY TO BE REJECTED AGAIN
AND AGAIN AND AGAIN TO PRODUCE
MORE OIL, I WOULD IMAGINE TEXAS,
OKLAHOMA, ALASKA WOULD BE VERY
OPEN TO PROCEEDING AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE IN TERMS OF OIL AND
WEST VIRGINIA AND PENNSYLVANIA
AND OHIO WOULD LIKE TO GIVE US
NATURAL GAS.
BUT WHAT DO I KNOW?
I'M JUST A TALK SHOW HOST.
>> YOU'RE RIGHT.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE IN PANIC MODE,
IN FREEFALL, BECAUSE THEY
CREATED THIS CRISIS.
I ENJOYED WATCHING YOUR VIDEO OF
PETE BUTTIGIEG TALKING ABOUT
WILD PRICE FLUCTUATIONS.
WHEN JOE BIDEN BECAME PRESIDENT,
THE AVERAGE PRICE OF GASOLINE
WAS $2.38 A GALLON.
TODAY, IT'S $4.23 A GALLON.
IT'S NEARLY DOUBLED IN 15 MONTHS
UNDER JOE BIDEN.
THEY'VE WAGED A WAR ON DOMESTIC
ENERGY PRODUCTION.
THEY CANCELED THE KEYSTONE
PIPELINE.
THEY SHUT OFF LEASES IN FEDERAL
LAND.
THEY SHUT DOWN DRILLING IN
ANWAR.
ALL OF THAT IS DELIVERED.
IT'S WHAT JOE BIDEN PROMISED.
HE TOLD DEMOCRATIC PRIMARY
VOTERS, IF YOU ELECT ME, I'LL
HALT DRILLING.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
THAT'S A PROMISE HE'S BEEN
WORKING OVERTIME TO KEEP, AND
NOW THE DEMOCRATS ARE IN PANIC
MODE, BECAUSE THEY REALIZE THAT
PEOPLE DON'T LIKE PAYING $4-6 --
YOU KNOW, IN CALIFORNIA IT'S
NEARLY $7 A GALLON FOR GAS AND
SO ON INFLATION, THE WHITE HOUSE
HAD FIVE SEPARATE LIES IN
INFLATION.
FIRST LIE IS, IT'S NOT
HAPPENING.
DON'T BELIEVE YOUR EYES.
THERE'S NO INFLATION.
SECOND LIE IS, OH, IT'S
TRANSITORY.
YES, IT'S HAPPENING BUT IT'S
JUST FOR A MOMENT.
THE THIRD LIE IS, IT'S A
HIGH-CLASS PROBLEM.
IT'S THERE, BUT IT'S A
AREN'T YOU LUCKY TO HAVE
INFLATION?
THEIR FOURTH LIE WAS, IT'S
HAPPENING, IT'S NOT TRANSITORY,
IT'S NOT HIGH CLASS, BUT IT'S A
GOOD THING.
IT'S A SIGN OF HOW GREAT THE
ECONOMY IS THAT YOU CAN'T AFFORD
TO PAY FOR YOUR GROCERIES OR PUT
GAS IN YOUR CAR.
THE THIRD LIE IS PUTIN, PUTIN,
PUTIN, THEY DECIDED POLITICALLY,
LET'S BLAME THIS TRAIN WRECK OF
A BIDEN ENERGY POLICY ON
VLADIMIR PUTIN.
THE GASOLINE PRICES HAVE RISEN
48% BEFORE PUTIN INVADED UKRAINE
AS THE STICKER SALE ON THE GAS
PUMP.
I DID THIS.
JOE BIDEN DID THIS!
>> Sean: WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF
THE PRESIDENT, FOR EXAMPLE -- I
THOUGHT HIS TRIP ABROAD WAS A
DISASTER TELLING OUR TROOPS, OH,
YOU'LL GET TO SEE IT IN UKRAINE
YOURSELF, REVEALING THAT OUR
TROOPS, AMERICA MIGHT BE
TRAINING UKRAINIAN TROOPS.
I DOUBT THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
MAYBE WE WANTED THE WORLD TO
KNOW OR VLADIMIR PUTIN TO KNOW.
I WOULD CONSIDER THAT A COVERT
OPERATION PLAUSIBILITY DENIAL
CATEGORY AND THEN -- DENIABILITY
CATER TO AND THEN CALLING FOR A
REGIME CHANGE AND THEN TO DOUBLE
DOWN AND DO IT AGAIN AFTER THEY
CLEANED UP THE MESS AND NOW
THERE'S NO WAY TO CLEAN IT UP
THIS TIME ON TOP OF EVERY GAS --
GAP HE MAKES.
YOUR OPINION?
>> IT'S GAP AFTER GAP AFTER GAP.
>> IS IT A GAP OR IS HE IN A
COGNITIVE DECLINE?
IT SEEMS TO BE OBVIOUS?
>> IT'S CLEARLY IN MAJOR
DECLINE.
I CAN TELL YOU IT'S STRANGE.
BIDEN, THEY DON'T ALLOW HIM TO
TALK TO MOST REPUBLICAN SENATORS
WHEN WE HAVE LUNCH TOGETHER,
REPUBLICAN SENATORS ALMOST TO A
PERSON NONE OF US HAVE SPOKEN TO
HIM SINCE HE BECAME PRESIDENT.
THAT'S WEIRD!
LOOK, JOE BIDEN SWORE ME INTO
OFFICE 10 YEARS AGO.
WE ALL KNOW HIM.
HE SERVED IN THE SENATE FOR FOUR
DECADES, BUT THE WHITE HOUSE IS
TERRIFIED THAT ANYONE WHO
INTERACTS WITH HIM REALIZES HE'S
NOT UP TO THE TASK, SO THEY KEEP
HIM PROTECTED.
THEY KEEP HIM ON TALKING POINTS.
THEY GIVE HIM A NARROW SCRIPT,
AND EVEN THAT HE SCREWS UP.
YOU'VE GOT THIS WAR IN UKRAINE.
JOE BIDEN CAUSED THIS WAR IN
UKRAINE.
HOW DID HE DO IT?
WHEN HE WAIVED SANCTIONS ON NORD
STREAM 2, SANCTIONS I AUTHORED
AND DONALD TRUMP SIGNED INTO
LAW, WHEN HE BUILT THOSE
SANCTIONS, PUTIN INVADED
UKRAINE.
THE PRESIDENT OF UKRAINE TOLD US
THE REASON PUTIN INVADED UKRAINE
IS BECAUSE OF NORD STREAM 2.
I GOT SAY, SEAN, IT'S AN AMAZING
THING THAT THERE'S ONE PIPELINE
AND ONE PIPELINE ON PLANET EARTH
THAT JOE BIDEN AND HIS CRONIES
LIKE AND THAT'S NORD STREAM 2,
BECAUSE IT HELPED VLADIMIR
PUTIN, BUT IF THEIR PIPELINES IN
AMERICAS CREATE JOBS HERE AT
HOME, THEY WANT TO SHUT 'EM ALL
DOWN.
>> Sean: PLAIN SPORE A
DIFFERENCE IF YOU -- EXPLAIN THE
DIFFERENCE IF YOU DRILLED FOR
OIL IN VENEZUELA, OPEC NATIONS,
IRAN, RUSSIA OR THE UNITED
STATES, EXPLAIN TO ME THE
DIFFERENCE IS IN TERMS OF THE
IMPACT TO MOTHER EARTH?
I WOULD ARGUE OUR GUYS DO IT
CLEANER AND BETTER THAN ANYONE
ELSE, BUT YET THEY'RE OK WITH
IMPORTING OIL AND BEGGING
TYRANTS FOR OIL BUT THEY'RE NOT
OK WITH DRILLING OUR OWN OIL AND
USING OUR OWN RESOURCES.
I CAN'T EXPLAIN THAT ONE.
CAN YOU?
>> YOU'RE EXACTLY RIGHT.
AMERICA PRODUCES OIL AND
PRODUCES GAS CLEANER THAN JUST
ABOUT ANYBODY ELSE ON EARTH AND
WHAT BIDEN HAS DONE IS HAMMERED
U.S. PRODUCTION AND SHIFTED
PRODUCTION OVERSEAS.
TO GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE OF THAT,
NATURAL GAS PRODUCTION IN THE
UNITED STATES AND TEXAS OR IN
PENNSYLVANIA OR OHIO IS SIX
TIMES CLEANER THAN PRODUCTION IN
VENEZUELA.
BUT BIDEN WANTS TO PUT BILLIONS
IN THE POCKETS OF MODURO IN
VENEZUELA AND ITOLL IRAN OR
PUTIN IN RUSSIA AND HE WANTS TO
DO IT AT THE SAME TIME THAT THEY
PRODUCE MORE OIL AND GAS THAT
POLLUTES MORE AND EMITS MORE
CO2.
HE'S NOT DOING THIS FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT.
THE ENVIRONMENT KEEPS GETTING
WORSE BECAUSE HE'S REDUCING
CLEAN U.S. PRODUCTION AND
SHIFTING TO DIRTY FOREIGN
PRODUCTION, BUT THE THING TO
UNDERSTAND WHEN I TALK TO
LEADERS IN THE ENERGY INDUSTRY
IS, LISTEN, YOU CAN'T TALK TO
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION WITH
FACTS OR REASON OR SUBSTANCE.
THEY'RE ZEALOTS.
THIS IS A RELIGIOUS CONVICTION.
THEY WANT TO BANKRUPT ALL
AMERICAN ENERGY DOMESTIC
PRODUCTION, AND YOU'RE SEEING
THE RESULTS AT YOUR GAS PUMP.